ryu has won his last two starts he's
been much better he's been pitching
deeper into the ball game
his stuff has been better his fastballs
had a little bit more velocity to it
and he is ready to go
and suck the other way that'll be into
left center for a base hit
so verdugo jumps on it red sox have
their first knock tonight
calls strike three movers didn't like
the call but ryu
will leave a base winner at first base a
single to alex verdugo
nothing more eduardo rodriguez the ace
of the boston red sox he'll get the
start tonight seven starts there are the
numbers for him era a little high at
four point
one five doesn't waste any time he jumps
on the first pitch and rips it into
center field
the blue jays are coming off a 16 hit
game
which ties their season high second time
they've had as many hits in a ball game
this year that was sunday when they
scored 10 runs
barter really taken a long time before
delivering and got him to go
up and away outside the strike zone
fly ball and that fairly well hit but
into right field there's renfro and he's
got it
to retire the side so no harm done or
under stranded at third
indeed he certainly worked hard it's a
tough hop for
denver as he can't make the play richik
is headed around first he'll get to
second
denver's trying to backhand that short
hop
and he went off his glove down the left
field line
for brando britchik
so here's kevin miggio hit left side
gritchix being stopped as verdugo was
very shallow in left field but kevin
jumped on the first pitch and picks up a
single
richard got third vizio at first two
down danny jansen
and i just got a base hit that's gonna
drive in the first run of the game danny
jansen
jumped on the first pitch blue jays are
up there ready to hack at eduardo
rodriguez tonight about that
swing not trying to do too much
basketball was away he just pounds it
through the right side of the infield
for his first hit of the ball game
up the middle and get through for a base
hit
he did he went to the same pitch that
cutter away
slapped to short the shovel onto second
one and the turn by gonzales in time for
the double play
that kills the inning one to nothing
toronto
he was always a guy there's a base hit
fair ball down the right field line this
could be extra bases that ball gets
stuck in the netting and gloria will end
up at second base
we'll finish that thought on veritek in
a minute
he's gonna loft that one into left
shallow verdugo charging on it dives
ahead
hangs on he's got it and right there
that win comes into play again
just knock that ball down one man out
excellent play by verdugo right there
charging hard all the way
allows him to catch that ball
same man loops it over the head that's
going to drop for a base hit here comes
korea
he's going to score to throw those to
third and right of the mark
here comes jansen and he's going to
score
renfro changed his sights mid-throat
he was coming up to throw home he
recognized he didn't have a chance
tried to make a throw to third and it
was nowhere close and the blue jays
scored two
trying to cash in the fourth
[Applause]
that ball is going to get down and go
past badugu
all the way to the warning trap simeon
is in the score
with another two-strike rbi
the double his ninth of the season
to do that but he's been doing a lot of
this
going the other way
boy oh boy i'll tell you what the blue
jays hitters
have really developed a great approach
going the other way and tasker hits the
lead off double
lately another pitch to the opposite
field base hit
renfrew's got a good arm here's the
throw it's offline
and guriel comes up with another rbi
single
blue jays hitters are going to
straighten out the shift before too long
there's a good pitch looked like he
threw up an inside cutter right there
choo choo pitch to bogo swinging a miss
what a change up by ryu
this is a different for you the red sox
are seeing than the one they saw at
fenway park he's on his game and he's
got a five-nothing lead
vladimir guerrero jr probably the
the biggest culprit of that ball that
ball is in front of renpo
and both thought about going to third
and
another opposite field base hit for the
blue jays
okay oscars had 11 home runs in fenway
park he's always good for at least
one there there's a base hit but
it's going to score easily guerrero will
stop in second ante oscars had a
three-hit
knight rbi number 19 for taylor
the blue jays lead at six to nothing
young jin ryu is shutting out the socks
on just four hits
3-2 pitch strike three again
where you had a red sox hitter thinking
of something else
renfro is called out on strikes three up
three down before the bottom of the
seventh
espinal gets a hit to the opposite field
so now all nine starters in the blue
jays lineup have a base hit tonight
danny gets another base hit espionage
will go to third
and there'll be no throw so danny jansen
another
multi-hit game for the blue jays
diving play by rafael devers he'll throw
and get him at first base
to retire the side an outstanding
sprawling play
by raphael
glady drills this one to the gap and
that's going to get down and go
all the way to the fence guerrero is
headed for
second with his third hit of the night
that's his eighth
double of the season
there's a drive to right it's got a
chance and no home runs not anymore
no gritsy goes opposite field uh
one shot his ninth i spoke too soon
i'm glad i did
don't sleep on the red sox folks i got a
good ball club
strike three call and that'll do it the
blue jays
win it they shut out the red sox on just
five hits young jin ryu set the tone
from the mound and the hitters took it
from there
wow boy did he ever seven innings
didn't give up a run didn't walk a
batter and then the blue jays
kept hitting and hitting